foreign
Orlando what's up Jeff
yes what's up man
not much you just saving the world dude
that's probably I didn't tell the truth
I'm not saying I'm not saving the world
I'm uh podcasting what's up man
I'm not much so
um we talk about in um your book on your
past on your future all about the
loneliness and everything
as someone that is
mostly working solo and you know Flying
Solo in day to day how do you make the
space to like build those relationships
and that you know authentic stuff and
not just have like a gazillion people oh
hey I know a guy
and you know actually have those like
real like real you know real friendships
real authentic stuff that's a great
question man thank you for asking that
question
um so I'm taking that you were you have
a solo job what do you do for a living
I work in the uh like Landscaping green
industry okay so you're you're you got
headphones on and you're cutting grass
and and weed eating all day long huh
yes pressure washing sweeping blowing
the whole thing right
yeah and unless I stop at like a gas
station or a Chick-fil-A or somewhere to
you know use the bathroom or
I forgot to pack lunch or something like
that I usually don't
interact with anybody okay and then are
you married or do you do you live alone
I live alone okay
So reading that book
um and on your past change of future
there's a whole chapter about loneliness
reading that book
it's probably unsettling to say the
least is that right
yeah because it's like yeah there's a
lot of people I know there's not a lot
of people that
oh hey you know
really you know I need someone to drive
me to the hospital at three o'clock in
the morning or
anything like that there's
no one sells that contact list
can I tell you how impressed I am with
you
to have the courage to say that out loud
because that's scary to say isn't it
yeah yeah dude I
um I'm proud of you for saying that now
the next step is you gotta go do
something about it right so
I think the first part of this shift and
change starts with an identity change a
shift in who I am
because right now you are a guy that
freaking gets it done
you work hard you're disciplined you
knock your lights out you do all the
stuff you're crushing it at work you're
doing it
and what I want you to do is to expand
that identity
and you are somebody
that is a great friend and has great
friends that's who you are
and it's a weird it's weird math and so
when I say weird math
it never would have occurred to me in a
million years that I would rather hang
out with my seven-year-old daughter than
some of my knucklehood knuckleheaded
friends from back in in when I was a kid
and my seven-year-old daughter cost me
all my money and takes up a lot of time
and doesn't always sleep through the
night
and you would think those things stacked
up against wanting to be around them
wouldn't work right because if you have
a friend that took all your money and
didn't want to be around and didn't
sleep all that you wouldn't want to hang
out with them
so that when I tell you the math doesn't
work like on parenting
I want to tell you the math doesn't work
on friendship either I don't understand
it
but here's what I know if you will
invest and work really hard as hard as
you do on your landscape stuff if you
will work that hard to get a couple of
guy friends in your life to start
hanging out to have a group of guys and
I'll walk you through a few few ideas I
have
if you will do that you will see
exponential growth in your business also
you'll see exponential return on your
health also unless y'all get together
and do stupid stuff
so you might think I don't have time for
this I don't have time for that I don't
know how it works or why it works but
the invested time in human relationships
and friendships always comes back
exponentially in your work okay
yeah so you're now a guy who has friends
and who is a great friend
sometimes for me that means
I call somebody on the way home from
work I start thinking about who I'm
going to call on the way to the parking
lot when I'm walking out and we just
chat on the phone it could be people
from all over the United States
from childhood when I was a little kid
to just a few years ago but I'll call
somebody on the way home just to check
in and chat and see how things are going
another one is
you can build time into
gathering places because a Cornerstone
of having friends is shared experiences
so it might be the gym it might be the
softball league it might be playing
chess start teaching guys at your local
church like hey I'm doing a how to fix
your mower how to do pressure washing
class after church if you want to come
hang another thing might be is once a
week you dedicate one half of a Saturday
to going around and mowing lawns for
people who don't have any money and you
invite some guys from you know your
church or from wherever to come with you
and what you're doing is you're doing
shared experiences and then everybody
pitches in and you'll get pizza or
you'll go grab lunch when it's all over
um here's all I can say is this you have
to be hyper extra intentional about it
so when I tell you that I know you've
already thought of some of those things
what is your pushback like it does it
sound stupid or Pie in the Sky when I
say those things
hopefully just the you know
be maybe I'll I almost want to say the
laziness of going
I don't even know if that's the right
word but going we'll you know get home I
want you know crack a cold drink and
turn on the TV and you know pop and you
know and The Lazy Boy and go up some
steaks and call it a day
and it's called I can't think of two
things as a grown man I would rather be
I would I would want to be called less
than a boy and lazy
and that's the name of most of our
prized possessions
that that glorious recliner
and so yes there is a lazy I don't say
laziness there is an intentionality
component you're gonna have to choose a
different kind of life it's going to be
uncomfortable for a while
my promises my promise is if you get two
or three guys that are coming over
having steaks with you a couple times a
week and they're bringing some of the
steaks and then one of them shows up
with catfish and one of them shows up
with venison whatever
and y'all are laughing and carrying on
and playing cards instead of
just watching TV
you will find a richness in your life
that you didn't know existed
I my my deeper question is
have you made it this far have you
always just kind of been a do it do it
on your own kind of guy or is this a
recent recent
um shift in your life
I had a lot of friends growing up like I
knew you know hung out and like and it
wasn't like a jock I wasn't exactly a
you know like chess team or you know
choir or you know I wasn't particularly
one
like you know particular group but had
people that I knew and various different
things and would hang out with
and do stuff but it was all it was
probably always like at least the
feeling of oh on the you know kind of
like the wall you know the wall flower
of on the outside looking end
can I ask you a hard question Jeff
sure
why don't you think you're worth having
friends
because I'd be willing to I'd be willing
to bet you money that's the most people
that you think you were just being a
Wallflower would count you as one of
their buddies
or to put it another way
I bet you a couple of those guys from
high school that you hung out with would
have called you if they gotten a mess
but yeah I know I've had a few people
that have called me because like they're
having
they need some extra work or you know
that kind of stuff but it's you know
it's like sometimes I guess sometimes
it's the quiet ones that you watch out
for
because those you know uh having you
know done a few various other jobs
it's like first you know you know or
people that I know that are in I've got
some people I know that like First
Responders and stuff and they it always
seems like they say
if white one says once No One Ever Knows
that stuff happens
and it's like well you know not I'm not
saying anything but on that it's just
like well
I'm always I always seem to find it
easier to be the one that people always
call
and it's hard to build the relationships
to actually say hey let's go do
pizza or let's you know throw some
steaks on the grill because because you
think that they don't want to be around
you
or that you don't want to bother anybody
Jeff you're you're not a bother
you have to you have to look inside
internally and believe that
people are going to be blessed by having
you on their life not the other way
around
nobody's life is better when Jeff is not
in it that's not true
people's life is better you make their
life better by your the job you do
you know what you give families
when you go mow their lawn and clean it
up
you know what you give them you give
them time with their families the single
most precious resource that's ever been
created in the history of the world
you give an exhausted mother and a
completely fried father
time with their family
like you're a gift man
and you also get to talk to all kinds of
wackadoo people every day
when you take money when you do their
yards with their requests and all that
kind of stuff you have a lot to offer
man
and it breaks my heart that you think
you don't
do you believe me when I tell you you do
yeah okay
then I want you to quit holding out on
the world and hiding Jeff from
here's what here's what I want you I
want you to pretend and or uh practice
make it a priority put it once or twice
on the count uh once twice a week on
your calendar I'm gonna call a couple of
folks to have them over
I'm gonna go first they can come to my
house and I'm not cleaning up for you
and they need to bring a side dish
and you're gonna you're gonna provide
the steaks in the grill and they can
bring beers they can bring
dessert whatever it is
and I want you to stay on the line I'm
gonna send you a whole bunch of packs of
questions for humans so you'll have
something to do yeah instead of just
staring at each other okay um that's
mean my gift to you
but you got to commit to practicing and
trying it and here's what I promise is
going to happen
a bunch of times guys aren't going to
show up
several times they're going to show up
and it's going to be super weird because
you're going to realize you vote for
different people and you're going to get
mad
but there'll be one or two or three of
the guys that you really sync with
y'all end up going fishing when one
Sunday afternoon
one of those guys bails you out when you
get sick and they cut your Lawns for you
and you cut them in on the deal
and you're going to realize those that's
my guy
those are my guys
and you're going to be those guys for
them
you see what I'm saying
yeah
it's changing your identity to I'm a guy
that is worth hanging around and it's
about being extra intentional I wish
there was all my heart man I wish there
was a hack to this one
I wish there was some secret like like
hidden algorithm for making friends
there's not you just gotta go risk it
just gotta go risk risk risk risk and
understand that if you just go home from
work every day to your lonely apartment
crack open a beer turn on the TV and
hang out with Ted lasso and all the cast
of the office instead of hanging out
with real people your life is going to
be shorter than other people and more
importantly it's going to be less rich
and less engaged and less joyful
it's not going to be a whole life
and it's not a matter of if it's a
matter of when the storms come you will
need other people other people are your
emergency fund for life you will need
them standing by your side
so
I say this from the bottom of my heart
Jeff
you're worth being friends with
go make friends
go be weird risk it all and if they
can't show up or they don't like you
that's on them has nothing to do with
you go on to the next and go on to the
next and go on to the next
you are worth having friends
hang on the line here we'll hook you up